what's up everybody
it's Warren and the spider man far from
home trailer has been out for a little
bit over a week now this has given
people plenty of time to dissect the
trailer to find all the Easter eggs and
figure out as much as they can about the
plot but here's the thing Marvel has
gotten really really good with their
trailers and really good at showing you
exactly what they want you to see and
since the trailer came out and Mysterio
appears to be a good guy people have
been wondering who are these new
villains the elementals well the
elementals are extra-dimensional
humanoids who became immortal with power
over the natural forces of the earth
water earth wind and fire and yes the
trailer does seem to make them out to be
pretty hardcore villains but here's the
thing they're not the true villains some
people have realized this and have began
to speculate on who the real villain
could be some have even began to
speculate that the Green Goblin slash
Norman Osborn could be the villain what
just happened this is due to an easter
egg in the spider-man far from home
trailer where we see the old Avengers
facility being remodeled many believe
that it is Norman Osborn who actually
bought this building for Oscorp and that
spider-man far from home will introduce
the Green Goblin into the MCU this very
well may be true and I hope it is but
the Green Goblin is not the main villain
or a villain at all in spider-man far
from home they won't introduce the
elementals Mysterio and Norman Osborn
slash to Green Goblin in one film sorry
to break it to you so who is the villain
in spider-man far from home if it's not
the elementals and it's not the Green
Goblin well despite what Marvel would
have you believe with the trailer it is
Mysterio he is the main villain in
spider-man far from home you don't want
any part of this
now I know a lot of people are saying
that they actually changed his character
in the MCU and he's a good guy now and
there's a lot of evidence for this in
the trailer he shows up and saves Peter
Parker and some other people from an
elemental and we know that Nick Fury
actually hires Mysterio to take care of
the elementals because he's supposed to
be an expert on them and at CC XP Jake
Gyllenhaal himself even said that
spider-man far from home is all about
their relationship between Mysterio and
Peter Parker but here's the deal
he never specified the relationship in
the comics Mysterio is a classic
spider-man villain his real name is
Quinton Beck and Quinton Beck wants to
be famous
Quinton Beck was one of the most
accomplished special-effects artists in
Hollywood but one of his friends
jokingly suggested that the quickest way
for him to become famous was to take out
a costumed hero but Quinton took this
rather seriously and realized that his
expertise in special effects and
illusions would actually make him a
pretty good supervillain so his plan was
to take out spider-man and then take his
place as a beloved superhero this is
mysterious plant and spider-man far from
home have no doubt about it
Mysterio is trying to appear like he's a
hero that way he can work with
spider-man and get close to him and have
him trust him so he can betray him and
take a spot as a hero that is loved by
everybody in the world and the way that
he makes it seem like he's a hero is he
takes on the elementals but as you saw
in the trailer the elementals even give
spider-man a hard time so how can
Mysterio take on these creatures well
it's because he probably made them again
Mysterio is a master of illusions and
special effects so it's most likely that
Mysterio created these elementals and
has them wreak havoc on cities so he can
show up defeat them and make it seem
like he's a hero but this is all part of
his master plan he wants to make
spider-man trust him so he can
eventually betray him and defeat him and
from there on out he can be the hero
that everybody loves so despite the fact
that he seems like he's a good guy in
the spider-man far from home trailer he
is actually the true villain of
spider-man far from home so let me know
your thoughts about Mysterio actually
being the true villain of spider-man far
from home let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and there's only
a few days left in my new round of the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero a new winner will be picked at
the end of the month as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]